No One Believes
our border is secure every state in the
country has become a border state with
this fentanyl crisis fentanyl is
attacking the streets of Oregon we had
our largest drug bust in Oregon's
history in my district this past year
this has got to stop and it starts with
the Secretary of Homeland stop lying to
the American public it's not a
Republican or Democrat issue it's an
American issue
I mean you just saw congresswoman
Jennifer kiggins one of those house
members who made that trip and she joins
us now congresswoman great to have you
on the program what did you see what did
you learn on a trip that the White House
refers to as a publicity stunt
good morning so it was great to be down
at the southern border with speaker
McCarthy and a group of Four Freshmen
and we went because we are focused on
problem solving we wanted to hear
directly from people who work and live
at the border we heard from the sheriffs
we heard from law enforcement we heard
from border patrol we talked to business
owners and ranchers and let me tell you
it is a crisis down there the borders
wide open we have a president who's not
doing his job this is directly a result
of the Biden Administration and their
weakness that they continue to show on
the border and the world is watching
this weakness but it is continues to be
a problem we were down there having
discussions learning about the cartels
who are really domestic terrorists who
are running the show and just the
problems the border patrol is having
with their Workforce you know having the
people available to to do the things
that they need to do to to uh you know
conduct the encounters and to find the
Fentanyl and to to be able to secure the
Border they don't have the Manpower they
don't have the resources so just that we
were saying that that rear its head just
with the increases in fentanyl deaths
like you were just talking about in the
cartels again who are running the show
are smart they are making lots of money
down there they are addressing people
from head to toe in camouflage they're
putting boots on their feet that are
that have carpets so that they are
harder to track and uh and they are they
are using scapegoats that are that are
then creating diversion so the border
patrol who has already Workforce
challenged is tied up with these
diversions which leaves the cartels then
to be able to find ways you know to to
get the drugs like been onto our country
uh it's a it's a safety issue it's a
community safety issue again and I said
not a Republican or Democrat one but
it's one that this Administration needs
to focus on you know we talk a lot about
fentanyl you've been talking about it
there the Pentagon says deaths among
active duty troops from fentanyl
overdoses are rising in 2017 36 percent
of those deaths were related to fentanyl
in 2021 it jumped to 88 percent this
just goes to show you no one is safe
what can we do to stop this
right it's the leading cause of death
for for Americans age 18 to 45 so it's
really impacting our young people and
Virginia our attorney general Jason
mahrez has a one kid one pill can kill
campaign that we've started here so
really uh you know everyone needs to
needs to know that it just takes such a
small amount we have enough fentanyl in
this country that's coming across our
border to kill every American you know
three times over so really that that
just understanding uh the danger that's
out there and it's in all of our all of
our States now I represent Virginia
congressional districts so so every
state is a border state yeah no one is
safe at this point that just goes to
show it congresswoman Jennifer kiggins
thank you so much I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis